hello world my guest today has a really
cool political commentary show on
youtube and he's actually about to hit 1
million subscribers
he's a really intelligent guy and he
makes me sound like a [ __ ]
please welcome david pakman
oh man so thanks again for doing this
man i know you're a super busy guy
especially with what you do and what's
going on right now in politics and these
days yeah
yeah there's so much stuff in the media
to digest
and to be able to talk about i feel like
you must be busy
yeah i think it's it's a lot of people
are confused when i say this but i think
it's actually good to limit the amount
of of stuff of inputs um
so i'll have some designated time to
figure out like what's happened in the
last 24 hours what do i want to talk
about tomorrow but then i also have
time to just totally unplug so usually
from the time i'm done with the friday
show
until i start preparing for the monday
show i'm not even paying attention to
what's going on in the news or politics
because it does get pretty toxic
and just exhausting so um i actually
it's
more important for me to find time to
just read things
that have nothing to do with news read
philosophy and history and
you know go biking and do that type of
stuff because otherwise just the burnout
is
is too it happens it happens to
everybody if you don't
yeah so what is your background like
what what
how did you get started in all this with
with commentary
and political your your show the david
pakman show
before all this started what were you
doing well
this started so long ago that i was just
in college
before the pre the pre david pakman show
era i was a junior in college and i was
sort of dabbling in college radio
reading sports scores at halftime on the
college radio station and that type of
thing and i liked something about
it but it wasn't that exactly
so when a community radio station
started up in northampton massachusetts
which is where i was i grew up
after moving to the u.s i just signed up
and basically was given an hour every
other week to do a show
and that's how it started it went from
once every other week to once a week
twice a week four times a week and then
you know for the last few years it's
been my full-time thing five shows a
week
wow so you right so currently you're
doing five shows a week
right we're a monday through friday show
and then on top of the hour show that we
do
for the podcast and the youtube clips
we'll do
a members only show for our paid
subscribers and then
lately there's a lot of live streaming
as well you know we had the conventions
we've got the debates upcoming so this
is like
these three months are like the busiest
of of the four-year phase
yeah one of my favorite things to watch
is when trump does the
when he addresses the media like in the
rose garden or whatnot and you'll
commentate over it
that's my favorite thing to watch yeah
and what's crazy is i
i started that on a whim and people
really seem to
like it and i think what what people
tell me is that
they have some sense that it's important
to listen when the president is speaking
but it's also
so unbearable for a lot of people in my
audience who don't like the president
where doing it in a community setting
with other like-minded people
is good and incredibly during the
republican national convention
some of our rnc streams actually had a
bigger audience than trump's own
youtube channel which is crazy to think
about wow
yeah do something interesting when
during the rnc
or the the the latest one he did that
was in front of the white house with the
white house in the background
i tried watching another person who was
doing something similar where they had
like their face in the bottom left
corner
and uh i think it was on the daily wires
channel
the guy was sitting there like drinking
some scotch or whatever and it was so
different to what you were doing because
he was just sitting there the whole time
like
exactly exactly exactly like he was just
like nodding his head agreeing with
everything the whole time and
it was just so weird just to see like
the difference in in uh
opinion or just like the way people are
who are on each side
yeah and i think you know if joe biden
were to win even though i'm gonna vote
for joe biden
i think that if i covered a similar joe
biden event i wouldn't be sitting there
just nodding along to everything i would
be critiquing it but from my perspective
which is you know to joe biden's left so
that's interesting that there's a crowd
that just like
liked it all and just kind of ate it up
do you think that
trump being president has sort of
helped this niche that you're in
this niche of like political commentary
or people that are more political
on their on their youtube channels or on
any other media platforms
absolutely and i've talked i've gotten
people who call in and they say
are you worried your show won't do as
well if joe biden is the president he's
like well it's not that i'm worried
i know it won't do as well if joe biden
is president
but that's okay and we're still i mean
listen if joe biden's president
if trump loses he'll be triggered for at
least six months if not longer so the
trump stuff is going to continue even if
joe biden wins that's number one there's
gonna be no shortage of trump stuff
i don't see him disappearing i see him
saying it was rigged i see him being
around
anyway uh but then we'll also have
republican obstruction like we saw
during barack obama's presidency so
we'll have that to talk about
and we'll also be able to critique joe
biden from the left
and so i don't think there's going to be
any shortage of material in a joe biden
presidency and by the way i'm not acting
like it's definitely going to happen we
could have another four years of trump
as well
so what do you see from your perspective
happening like as far between now
and the election what do you see
happening and
why do you see that happening so one of
the things i've been predicting for a
while
is that at some point in october trump's
going to say we got a vaccine
and um it is going to have nothing to do
with donald trump
because trump is not in the business of
getting vaccines the vaccine may even be
from a pharmaceutical company or
university in another country
but my prediction was that donald trump
would say i did it we got a vaccine
vote for me and in fact we just learned
about the trump cdc sending out a letter
to states
on august 27th saying be prepared
for a vaccine in late october
and so i think it's very clear at this
point that if they need to make an
emergency use authorization to claim
that they got a vaccine
they've determined that it might help
trump get reelected
if he can take credit for a vaccine so
i'm almost certain we're going to see
that before november 3rd
what do you think is going to happen
with the debates
do you think that those are actually
going to happen do you think that biden
is going to participate in that yeah i
mean so as of now everybody's agreed to
three presidential debates and one vp
debate
um the dates are on the calendar you
know they started in late september
i do think there's a question of is it
possible that there's some disagreement
over the parameters
and it ends up with somebody saying i'm
out so for example joe biden has asked
for a live
fact checker during the debates which i
think is obviously to his advantage and
it's not to trump's advantage i don't
see any way trump
goes for that so that could cause a
problem you know hopefully the networks
that are carrying the debates will be
live fact-checking but i think the idea
of an official live fact checker
trump's not going to go for that i don't
think there's any way but it's
possible that some of these
disagreements could end up getting
somebody to walk away i think
i i've said before i don't really need
debates this time around i mean
i'm fully decided it's really hard for
me to imagine anybody being undecided at
this point
but if joe biden were to say i won't
debate i think it would be objectively
bad for him particularly when there are
people that are making the case that
biden cognitively isn't there
i don't think it would be good optics
for biden to back out i think trump
could back out with
less uh of a repercussion but i still
don't think it would be good for either
to say i'm not going to debate
yeah the debates it seems like the
debates are just a lot more for
entertainment right
a lot more like they're entertaining
they're good for tv
you can make a lot of money with the ads
the ad space during the debates because
everybody's going to watch them
yeah i mean i think one of the issues
there's two issues one i've never seen
donald trump
speak in depth about any issue so so if
the format
allowed for 40 minutes on
one question i think it would be very
bad for donald trump because that he's
not shown
me ever that he can talk about an issue
in that depth
the other problem is it never gets to
that because the format of the debates
is meant to be more entertaining and
less substantive so
they don't want to talk about one thing
for 40 minutes either
like a point to the debates is you're
not going to change anybody's vote
do you think like i don't think anybody
who voted
in 2016 who's voting this year i don't
think
a debate is going to change anyone's
mind at this point
my instinct is the same as yours and i
recently interviewed a political
scientist named rachel bittikoffer who
feels very strongly that really it's
about activating people who are already
on your side or suppressing the vote of
the other side more than it is about
changing people's minds
and if you think about it like at the
personal level if you
had to either change someone's mind or
just get somebody who already agrees
with you to go out and vote it's much
easier to find people who agree with you
and just to encourage them to vote than
it is to actually change minds
so the debates i don't think are likely
to change
too many minds unless something goes
really wrong like if you really make a
mistake that that can change votes
but the debates could activate
different constituencies and maybe
affect turnout
what are like the biggest talking points
that you've that you've seen
that that people get riled up about the
most on the left like as far as i know
one of the big things is uh
you know obviously health care and and
like a living wage right
so on any particular policy you know
the left is a spectrum so to say here
are the issues where my views are
different than the left's
it sort of ignores that that everything
is on a spectrum
i i think right now the most important
and pressing issues if you look at the
data
are coronavirus the economy and race
relations
so certainly like in 2016
the minimum wage was a big big thing is
the
democratic party going to support a 12
or a 15
an hour minimum wage or what's going to
be the minimum wage during the
the democratic debates this year there
was a lot of debate about elizabeth
warren's wealth tax
versus bernie sanders tax plan versus
joe biden wanting to uncap taxes on
social security you know there's all
these different proposals right now
americans are saying coronavirus is the
top issue
and on that joe biden is very much ahead
of trump
number two is the economy and obviously
that relates to coronavirus because the
reason we have the economy we have right
now is because of coronavirus
and number three race relations and all
three of those are not particularly good
for donald trump now republicans are
typically strong on the economy
and even right now there are polls that
have trump ahead of by none the economy
but by
very very little often the republican
candidate
is five ten points ahead on who will
better deal with the economy
the latest fox news poll has trump one
point ahead on the economy so
those are really the three big issues
right now
why so why is he not much farther ahead
on the economy
in your view well i think people
recognize that
the economic destruction of the virus is
worse than it had to be
because of his handling of the virus in
other words trump didn't create the
virus of course
and every country had to deal with it
but other countries dealt with it in a
way
that was more responsible and thus they
mitigated the economic damage
i've heard you use the term before what
is an enlightened
centrist can you explain this to me sure
i found this interesting
so um there's kind of a there's a
movement
of people and when i say this
this could be like your friends on
facebook like i have friends on facebook
that fall
into under this umbrella or
there's media pundits that fall under
this umbrella like it's it exists kind
of everywhere
yeah people who see politics and
they sort of position themselves as
being above the partisan fray
they don't fall for the left's talking
points
and they don't fall for the rights
talking points they are
in the middle and they are objective
and they are sort of unbiased arbiters
of what each side says and it
these are really people who are playing
characters it doesn't it doesn't
really exist in the way that they want
us to think of it which
is you can't believe these folks because
they're partisan in this way and you
can't believe those folks because
they're partisan and that way you can
believe me
because i've found enlightenment so
enlightened is a sort of tongue-in-cheek
right
yeah they've found enlightenment they've
found the sort of
truth and it happens to be right in the
middle of two sides
you know the odds of that being the real
truth are very low
and of course nobody is really above
bias we all are constantly dealing with
with our own biases and the idea that
somebody could have sort of seen the
light and gotten outside of that
paradigm is very hard for me to believe
i i definitely see what you're saying i
feel like i talk to a lot of people who
are like this
a lot of people that are more
philosophical they like to speak in the
philosophical terms and
and you know people that are really
educated on history and they can say
go back to historical events and you
know
make it seem like they're being very
objective and they're not biased in one
way or another
well sometimes there's a confusion
between neutrality and objectivity which
i think is important
which is neutrality is like a position
like i can say
i'm neutral on whether climate change is
being affected by human activities
or not right that's a position that i'm
taking
but objectively the science is
overwhelming so
if i want to assess the evidence
objectively
i couldn't possibly come out neutral
right 99.98 of the science is
at least to some degree human activity
on earth is affecting what's going on
with the climate
so could i
claim neutrality of course but i that
wouldn't be objective
because it would not be actually
dictated by the facts and so i think a
lot of times there's a confusion
between neutrality and objectivity
they're very different things
especially when it comes to climate
change for sure um
there was like something that recently
came out yesterday or the day before
about congress not being able to get
briefings from intelligence briefings so
the united states has all of these
different intelligence agencies
different agencies that work in
different areas they have they focus on
different things
and they brief both
members of congress as well as elected
officials
and when we're at this phase in the
presidential campaign
the the nominee on the other side the
challenger
also starts to get those briefings so if
you go back to 2016
you might remember that not only was
barack obama briefed about this
trump dossier but donald trump as the
republican nominee was also briefed
about the trump dossier
and so the idea there is that if trump
were to win
he would enter and already kind of have
some information about what the
intelligence community
has been paying attention to and this
also applies to the house and senate so
even though the
intelligence agencies right now many are
headed up by people that donald trump
chose the idea is that intelligence is
so crucial to national security
that the intelligence agencies have a
role to a responsibility to inform
both everybody regardless of their party
affiliation
well a few weeks ago the briefing
started to contain material
that included russia's trying to meddle
again
and they prefer donald trump among other
things this was not the only thing right
you know
china has preferences iran has pro okay
and the decision was made after news of
these briefings
broke that democrats
were no longer going to be briefed by
intelligence agencies
in the normal way they would get like a
couple page written report normally
these are like in-person briefings or at
least
teleconference in the age of coronavirus
and it seems like a very clear partisan
move
to just sort of limit the possibility
that again it becomes a news story that
russia has preferences here and the
preferences are
the preference is not joe biden yeah so
in the first election
obviously russia was doing a lot of [ __ ]
on social media like
a lot like a lot of targeting like
especially on facebook right with like
pushing certain things towards certain
people trying to get people riled up in
their own little echo chambers on
facebook
what specifically are they trying to do
as far as meddling in this election what
what matters is what do intelligence
agencies say that they're they're doing
and
again the information has been clamped
down so i wish we knew more about
exactly what they were doing but it
would probably be in line with
with what they always do which is you
want to
uh foment unrest and create an
environment where people question
whether democracy is functioning so like
as an example
if people are questioning whether their
mail-in ballots are going to be counted
that's something that plays right into
russia's hands
as an example uh if people are unsure
uh whether they will know the day after
or the week after the election who
really won which is by the way an idea
that donald trump has been promoting
that plays into russia's hands and i
think it's really important to mention
a lot of people when they hear russia
they start throwing around the term
russiagate
they say that these are conspiracy
theories etc
there's really nothing secret about any
of this and so
it is true that russia has done this for
decades
and to many countries it's not just the
united states
it's true that the united states has
meddled in elections
in other countries so all of these
things are true
countries regularly try to affect
outcomes in ways that are favorable to
them
for russia specifically the idea is if
russia wants to be taken more seriously
on the world stage
what what is in their interests is to
make western democracies look like they
aren't functioning very well
and having a presidential candidate like
trump
publicly questioning whether you can
trust the election results plays
right into that idea what is your
perspective on what happened with
kyle rittenhouse or what's his name
written house
rit ian kyle rittenhouse and what's
going on with him he's in he finally he
turned himself in right
and now he's he's got a lawyer who's
going on tucker carlson
saying that he was completely it was
completely self-defense he had every
right to be out there with his gun and
and there's a lot of it just seems like
this is the kind of thing that
fuels people yeah so a couple of
different things on this i mean first of
all i actually don't think that this is
really going to be a big issue for the
election come november but i'll talk
about why
in a little bit let's first just talk
about you know what happened
so there's going to be a legal case here
there's going to be
a uh there's a prosecution that's in
progress for
double homicide and i don't know exactly
what other charges have been brought
against kyle rittenhouse
and there may be a plea there may be a
trial
we just don't know yet so from from the
legal perspective
whether any of what took place with
self-defense is going to be adjudicated
there's going to be a process for that
and you know trial by media is not
particularly useful what we're seeing
are a couple different things
so you have some people who are saying
that what happened here was sort of a
cold-blooded
murder by kyle rittenhouse that would be
sort of like one side
and on the other side you do have people
including some right-wing pundits
and even kyle rittenhouse's attorney
john pierce i believe his name is
who are sort of framing kylo some kind
of hero that
his marksmanship is amazing his
self-control is amazing that he was he
only shot a couple of people when many
other 17 year olds would have shot way
more than two people in those situation
really really kind of a very different
perspective
um you know the self-defense component
is going to be different in each of the
two counts i think
i think in the second count it's going
to be something that's more plausible
than in the first but again i want to
try to
stay away from from sort of like trial
through videos
right i think the real problem is a
cultural problem
where you know this is a 17 year old kid
who crossed state lines now initially
there were people saying that he
brought the guns across state lines it
was later alleged that actually someone
in wisconsin gave him the gun
it's irrelevant because if you're under
18 in wisconsin you can't be carrying
around a gun anyway
so so that's number one giving the kid a
gun
was also a crime so that you know if you
really want to get into it you're just
going to go into this kind of black hole
of these different details but
the idea that we should be celebrating
vigilante 17 year olds with long guns
that's a major cultural problem for me
in the united states and then you'll
have
of course some who are saying and tucker
carlson has said
listen if you can't trust the police
isn't it natural in some sense that a 17
year old kid with a rifle would be the
one policing no it's not natural
there's nothing natural about that
whatsoever and so for me that's like
where
you know there's going to be a trial all
of these details are going to be
adjudicated that's a real cultural
problem that i don't know how we
overcome
yeah there's something really wrong with
with having your
17 year old kid
patrolling the streets with an automatic
ar-15
like especially you're 17 there's
you're not even a fully developed human
yet and
you're you have the power that kind of
power in your hands
and not only that but you're thrown
into this chaos where there's going to
be conflict no matter what
so like i think it's a not only a
cultural problem for sure but like the
parents where the [ __ ] are this kid's
parents at
yeah and you know that gets complicated
because
the where are the parents is also used
by some on the right to justify
law enforcement treating poor and
non-white youth
in a way that we know is completely
counterproductive so i
you know where are the parents is very
relevant but we i also want to be
careful with just throwing that off as
a sort of blanket thing um but
you know when people get into this stuff
about well listen
this was a good guy with a gun because
he also had a first aid kit
or this is a bad guy with a gun because
two weeks before he sucker punched a
teen
girl it really misses the bigger
cultural point that i think you and i
are kind of making here
either way it's just it's just [ __ ] up
period
for a 17 year old to be carrying a
weapon like that out in the middle of
the streets
in the middle of a riot like that like
there's the kid there's no place for him
to be there
at the same point you know there's no
point for you know
not making any excuses for anybody but
the guy who like ran up behind him
trying to hit him in the head like
why would you run up behind a kid with
an automatic weapon trying to take him
out like it just seems like
a bad idea on both sides yeah sure and
you know you can make the case that the
person who ran up behind him
saw the guy with the gun as a threat and
wanted to stop
the threat and that it was maybe
ill-conceived i mean
this is the problem what we know is a
problem is a 17-year-old
in a different state than the one in
which he lives illegally walking around
with a rifle right that's
that's definitely a problem the other
stuff a lot of it is
you know details that are going to have
to be sorted out on top of all of it i
don't i just don't feel like
i feel like one of the best arguments
against trump is that you know he is not
being a leader the way he talks to
people like when you're when you're
constantly just making
excuses and blaming other people
and just talking the way you do and just
being talking [ __ ]
24 7 about anybody and everybody on
twitter
it's not somebody that you can
i just don't feel like he has those
characteristics of a leader that you
would want to run a country especially
the most powerful country in the world
well obviously that's my perspective um
but i think that
you don't have to only ask the opinions
of
partisan americans to get a valid
opinion on that if you look around the
world
you know the united states under trump
is not part of more and more
important conversations conversations
about climate conversations
you listen to the u.s trump announced
that he will not be joining the global
effort
for equitable distribution of a
coronavirus vaccine
you know we're just out of a lot of
important conversations that we should
be leading on
instead of just not leading we're not
even in a lot of these conversations
it's it's a it's a
embarrassing but under coronavirus with
the death toll approaching 200 000
it's not just that countries are
laughing at us they actually pity us i
mean it's a real
change compared to what the united
states was under previous
administrations
what is your opinion on health care
and like where we're at now and what can
be fixed like what what do you think
like the best case scenario for
health care in the country would be
under joe biden if you got elected
sure so joe biden's plan on health care
is not medicare for all
that's very clear and he says he's not
for medicare for all
but if joe biden gets his way he's going
to be able to do some
pretty important things so one is joe
biden would create
a public option and you know the public
option
is is where barack obama started the
negotiation
with obamacare and it ended up being
negotiated away
and a public option is no panacea but it
would be a really important thing to
have a public option it would put
downward pressure on prices from private
insurers
and it would be a really great thing to
have joe biden has also talked about
significantly increasing subsidies for
people to reduce the number of people
that are without health care to make it
more affordable again it's like
there are better plans that are more
comprehensive but if joe biden could do
both of those things it would give
millions of additional people
health care uh people who don't have it
right now and then
biden has said he would be open to
lowering the age where you can get
medicare so currently it's 65 and
if that were lowered to 60 or 55
that's also millions of americans who
could get on medicare who currently
can't
so you know is it is it
nothing no it's these are significant
proposals
is it medicare for all certainly it's
not is it going to get
everybody health care no it'll get
relatively close but it's not going to
get everybody health care
but these would be i mean listen when
you compare to the trump proposals of
2017
which would have kicked about 25 million
people off of health care
if you can if you give me the option
take health care away from 25 million
or give it to 25 million more you know i
know which one i choose every time
yeah i hear a lot i hear a lot of
arguments i mean you're in boston i'm in
florida i'm in like what the i'm on like
the west coast of florida
throughout my life and my upbringing
i've always thought of
republicans as being wealthy people who
don't want to
pay a lot of money and don't want to pay
a lot of tax right
and what i've noticed more and more and
more in the last couple years
is that a lot of the people who are
trump supporters
especially around here who i just have
everyday conversations with
one of their biggest reasons for being
trump supporters is not wanting to pay
tax
and wanting to pay less tax and they say
that you know the democrats will
socialize everything
and you know commies blah blah blah
and more and more of the most outspoken
trump supporters
aren't even in uh they're
probably one in one of the lowest tax
brackets so
this has been studied pretty extensively
because you're right that if you look at
it and you say wait wait
why do these trump supporters
want taxes lowered for people who earn
way more money than them like
it doesn't make doesn't seem to make any
sense um one person who studied this
quite a bit is jonathan
he's a social psychologist and what he
has found
is that it seems as though the behavior
is irrational at the individual level
like yes
lower someone else's taxes and not mine
that doesn't really seem to make sense
but what jonathan height found is that
it's consistent with group
priorities so if you are a republican
and you identify
in total with the package of
republicanism
and that can include whatever is
important to you in it right it could be
being against abortion or being against
gay marriage
or what what could be anything that you
were sort of saying
this policy of lowering tax on people
that are far richer than i am
is good for my group and even if it's
not good for me in a direct way
because it's good for my group as i've
been told i'm gonna go for it anyway and
it really comes down to group priorities
and you can find like evolutionary stuff
to to support this
and their psychology material to support
it but that's the gist of it where it's
like that's what explains
people supporting policies that don't
really seem like they would actually
benefit them
yeah it's more of the tribalism coming
out right yeah and tribalism has become
a sort of fraught term in the sense
that it's now thrown around sometimes
appropriately and sometimes not
and it's used as a pejorative and you
know but
from it from an evolutionary social
psychology standpoint there's a lot of
scholarship that explains this pretty
well
i want to go back i watched an interview
recently with a guy kyle kolinsky where
he's talking about
he gives the example of um walmart
executives trying to
convince their convince their employees
to sign up for
programs so they can actually afford to
live
while earning their low income wage
working for walmart
are you familiar with this no i was
looking for it as you were mentioning it
i have not i've not seen that
um okay i think it was a conversation
about about a living about living wage
like raising the minimum wage
across the board so so that way people
don't have to
work two jobs to survive or you know
work two or three jobs to have a roof
over their head
i see all these things as different
things they're all related to
what is the worst situation that we as a
rich country
should allow anybody to be in
fundamentally that's what this is about
um is it okay for people to die of
hunger in the united states
there are some who would say it is okay
and there are others who say we're such
a wealthy country
there's no reason anybody should ever
have to die of hunger in the united
states that's a really easy thing that
we can figure out if we kind of put our
minds to it
so on minimum wage
at absolute minimum the minimum wage
should have kept up
with inflation dating back to 1968 is
often used as a number when the modern
uh
living wage minimum wage era has started
it hasn't
so like without even debating anything
there should at least be uh an
adjustment of the minimum wage
to inflation matching the late
60s now that's like really easy and
you'll still find people who don't even
agree with that
when it comes to living wage i i
do think that it's complicated by the
fact that
the country is huge and cost of living
is
really different from state to state and
even within states like the state of new
york has new york city
one of the most expensive places in the
country and it has these
ultra rural spots you know far from new
york city that are some of the cheapest
places to live in the country
so we need to figure out what we
mean by living wage sometimes people
look at can you rent a two-bedroom
apartment on the salary
the average salary so like if the
average salary in new york city
doesn't allow you to rent an average
two-bedroom or
any two-bedroom then that's probably too
low
of a salary there but there will be
people who hear that and say well nobody
says you have to
live in new york city to work in new
york city okay fine so that kind of
becomes a debate
but that probably needs to be
regionalized to figure out what is it
that
based on cost of living needs to be paid
to everybody basic income's a whole
other idea
basic income conceptually is the idea
that as a society we are better off
when nobody is in a situation of
desperation which i agree with
and that by spending money on the
upfront
to ensure that nobody is
literally out of money i mean still some
of these basic income proposals are
pretty modest you're not really going to
live any kind of
good life in a lot of the country on
that
um that we are actually doing something
that's going to be good in the long run
uh that when people have enough money
for food they're not likely to steal as
an example you know there's all these
kind of societal benefits from it but
that's a bit of a different question
than minimum wage
okay yeah no one of the reasons so
quickly what is the argument against
raising minimum wage with inflation um
so there's a you you'd really have to
ask someone who opposes it but my
instinct is that some people would say
that there's that there's
some that it's arbitrary to say it
should be tied to inflation that it
should be tied to something else or that
it was too high before or whatever
there's others that say it would be too
costly for small business
there's others who would say no the wage
really should be this low
for minimum wage jobs because their
minimum wage for a reason and they're
not meant to be living wage jobs
you know you i'm not a good spokesman
for why we shouldn't raise it because i
think clearly we should
right i had this discussion with a close
friend of mine who owns his own
construction company the other day
it's he explained it's really really
difficult
to find entry-level laborers who
have a driver's license who have their
[ __ ] together enough to be able to show
up to work on time every day
to to be able to show up to work every
day of the week you know
um he he has to filter through tons and
tons of entry-level job
people to be able to get somebody to
stick just at minimum wage
and the people who do come in at minimum
wage they typically don't have
a background or they don't have a skill
set
to bring to the job that's gonna benefit
them basically they come in knowing
nothing
they have to they come in basically with
a blank slate they learn
how they learn how the industry works
they learn how to do their job and if
they stick around
for long enough for six months to a year
they can get promoted they have the
opportunity to make more money to build
a
career and to very quickly earn up to
like six figures
working in a construction in a in the
construction industry being like a job
supervisor
things like that um and he said his
argument is if you raise a minimum wage
what's the incentive
to go do to go work out in the hot sun
in florida
you know i can sit at home make 800
bucks a week and not do anything when
why would you want to go bust your ass
in the hot sun making 15 an hour
okay so there's two different things
there i mean the making more sitting at
home
is a very temporary thing because of the
enhanced unemployment because of
coronavirus
it applied to very few people it's it's
temporary i don't know that it deserves
too too much
discussion necessarily the other one is
interesting because
it sounds like what your friend is
saying is
why would somebody earn minimum wage
with me in the hot sun
when they can go earn minimum wage at
mcdonald's
and that to me suggests that he
shouldn't be paying minimum wage it
sounds like
he is not actually in the business of
minimum wage jobs he should be paying
more already right i mean
if if the complaint is i pay minimum
wage
and mcdonald's pays minimum wage and
people are just going to go to
mcdonald's
then that sounds to me like it should
drive up the wage that he's paying and
he would then get better people who
would prefer to do
what they could do with him at a higher
wage than to be at mcdonald's right or
am i missing something
so right now i think he pays a little
bit more than minimum wage
so so these other jobs like mcdonald's
or other things
that require less skill or that are
easier they're not outside um if they
raised the wages of those to to meet his
starting wage
it would reduce the incentive right now
there's 11 percent unemployment so
there's a lot of people looking for jobs
i think in the immediate if that were to
happen
i don't think it would have a big impact
on the fact that
11 of the country is still unemployed
and a lot of people are looking for jobs
there's a theoretical discussion there
which is a common one
which is if every job
pays more comparatively people earning
slightly above minimum wage now
feel like hey now i'm at the minimum
because everybody else got a raise
and i didn't uh that's a real thing
that we we know that often the people
most opposed to minimum wage increases
are the people making just above minimum
wage so psychologically that's very true
it's not really useful to us in terms of
policy though there's a contingent that
thinks
minimum wage isn't supposed to be a
living wage these are
temporary jobs that are okay place your
passion through
on your way to something else the
unfortunate reality is for as long as
businesses are allowed to pay
living with minimum wages that are so
low
they're going to continue doing it so
someone's permanently going to be in
that situation and so the problem i have
with
you know the the analogy you present is
that it's really like a scarcity
mentality
but if you actually realize that this is
one of the richest countries
in the world we should really have an
abundance mentality which is nobody
should
there's no reason for anybody to be
hungry there's no reason for anybody
uh to to be poor if we decided to fix it
when you apply a scarcity mentality
you can justify a lot of really weird
things but when you recognize the
position that the united states is
actually in
very quickly you realize that just
allowing a lot of this stuff to happen
because it sounds like it's natural is
it
is quite frankly immoral yeah that's a
very good point i agree with that
i am completely an idiot when it comes
to this kind of stuff
and i think it's i think it's amazing
what you're doing and i love i love the
content you're putting out
i really appreciate the invite thank you
[Music]
you